why are we so obsessed with others
faults that's the topic I want to unpack
today my name is Brett silver pastor at
the table in Sachse Texas and welcome to
Table Talk where each week I unpack
insights and ideas from Christian
theology spirituality culture that help
you become a more thoughtful calm just a
wonderful human being so I recently
finished a marvelous old book titled the
spirit of st. Francois juice alb which
is about the life and teachings of this
fabulous Christian Saint so Saint
Francois he was born in 1567 he was a
bishop in the city of Geneva in France
for many years and really he was someone
who over time became known for his
wisdom in his kindness but in this book
I came across the following quote from
him he said this men who are curious
into their inquiries in the lives of
others are mostly careless about
correcting their own faults and I love
that you used the word curious you
almost hit the sort of a picture of a
person who's like an investigator or
scientist not of crimes or of physics or
something but of the faults of other
people and me but then he goes even
further and sees that there's a
connection between those folks interest
in almost obsession with others faults
and an avoidance of their own and this
leads me to a principle that our great
temptation is to avoid our own faults
and shortcomings by becoming preoccupied
with the false in short
means of others now why does this tend
to be the case I think it's captured in
that one word avoidance right to put it
poetically all of us are tempted to
avoid our own crap and sometimes we
avoid it through like distraction
other times we avoid it through
addiction but one of our favorite ways
to disguise the fact that we are
avoiding our own weaknesses and
shortcomings is our obsession with other
people's weaknesses and shortcomings in
fact the family therapist Edwin Freedman
whom I love and I quote a lot he pointed
out that generally every family has one
person that he calls the identified
patient this is the person that everyone
and the family system agrees is the
problem it's their alcoholism or their
lack of people skills or their inability
to hold down a job or whatever the
latest dramatic thing is and everyone's
constantly focused on it and talking
about it behind their backs of course
because god forbid we ever have a direct
conversation with him now here's the
thing it may be true that they really
aren't alcoholic or lack social skills
or whatever I mean they really may be a
dysfunctional mess but here's the key
the identified patient concept is naming
that so often the family not only begins
to revolve around them in their
dysfunction but they actually become an
excuse for me not growing up in in
facing my own crap right and this can be
either explicit or implicit by explicit
I mean we might literally say well I
just I just can't move on or I just I
just can't focus elsewhere like I can't
set those goals or work on myself cuz
I'm distracted by them I gotta take care
of them I gotta talk endlessly about
them or more often though it's implicit
and unconscious
having another conversation about them
is easier than working on me even though
consciously I may be not aware that
that's what I'm doing but that's what
I'm doing all right so what's the answer
what do we do well we've got to become
more curious about our own faults our
own weaknesses our own shortcomings
we've got to pay attention to our
dysfunction to our patterns of avoidance
and as best we can we've got to begin to
cultivate a healthy indifference about
the weaknesses and faults of others so
for example when you Journal make it
about your own weaknesses when you pray
make it about your own shortcomings not
theirs when you speak to others talk
about your own struggles not theirs and
not just your weaknesses but also um
start to focus on your goals and your
strengths and your growth edges right
pay attention to the god instilled
potential in yourself rather than the
faults of others that's the path to
growth in maturity so that's all for
today if you enjoyed this video please
click the like button subscribe share
comment you know all the things and to
ensure you don't miss future episodes go
ahead and subscribe to my youtube
channel or to my podcast on really most
any platform by searching Brett's Alfred
tabletalk grace empties